So, you now have two very similar problems
for genome assembly, but
it turned out that these two problems have
very different algorithmic fates.
In the Eulerian path problem, we want to
find
a path visiting every edge of the graph
exactly once.
In the Hamiltonian path problem, we want
to
find a path visiting every node exactly
once.
It sounds like small, cosmetic and
unimportant information.
Let me ask you a question.
If you were given the possibility
to choose between the Hamiltonian Path
Problem
and Eulerian Path Problem as presented in
this slide what choice would you make?
Son?
>> Son: Well, I would like to solve the
Eulerian path
problem because the graph on the right
looks simpler, and
maybe it's easier to find a path that
traverses all the edges in the graph.
>> Son just gave a very wrong answer.
It doesn't matter that the one graph looks
simpler than another.
In real life, this graph will contain
millions, if not billions of
edges, and it doesn't matter that one of
them contains 2 million and
another contains 1 million of edges.
What matter is whether we have
efficient algorithms for solving this
problem.
And it turns out that the different
algorithmic fate of this problem is
related
to the fact that Euler actually
found an algorithm for efficiently solving
the Eulerian path problem
00:01:40,322 --> 00:01:44,620
Path Problem but a generation of computer
scientists failed
to find an efficient algorithm for
Hamiltonian path problem.
In fact, the Hamiltonian path problem
belongs to a class of so called
incomplete problem that contains thousands
of computational
problems for which algorithms are still
unknown.
For some time,
computer scientists tried to find out
whether
this problem can be solved in principle or
whether maybe there is not
even an efficient algorithm for solving
this problem.
Maybe even God cannot solve this problem
efficiently.
But, it turns out to be very difficult to
prove that there
is no efficient algorithm for this problem,
and in fact, the Hamiltonian
path problem belongs to one of
seven millennium problems of mathematics
that remain unsolved.
However, what computer scientists were
able to prove is that all
NP-complete problems, which means thousands
of problem from this class are equivalent.
Or in other words if you solve any of
these problems you will solve the
Hamiltonian path problem.
And as a result, our failure to solve the
Hamiltonian path problem becomes a little
bit less upsetting.
Because we know that we failed to solve it
but we
also know that thousands of computer
scientists also failed to solve it.
And since our chances to solve this
problem are slim, from now on we will
focus on the Eulerian path problem.
And we'll study in more details.